hola [ __ ] if you guys want to
catch us in podcast form you guys
actually can and you can see that links
in the description box below if you want
to know how to get to them and remember
if you like what we're doing here give
us a 5-star rating because we need those
[ __ ] in didn't see doctor news
ooh get a scalpel in his butt crack and
a flew out and somebody's ass submitted
by JK come to Shanghai I heard they have
great dumplings there something positive
about China I want to go to China but I
don't want to travel through China you
know I mean I want to be like dropped in
like but I heard that Shanghai is a bit
different from China China true it is oh
really
yeah it's kind of like Hong Kong where
it was like property of somebody else
property maybe the pledge of geese I
don't know the Dutch I don't know don't
know my history that whale sounded
convincing a dermatologist is defending
herself after filming funny videos while
operating on unconscious paint patients
oh that's all like what you do [ __ ] in
the guy's mouth you're not supposed to
do that that's like a patient
confidential thing right yeah you can't
be making fun of your patients oh really
they entrusted you I personally don't
mind as long as I don't find out I have
a [ __ ] like illness like I'm a dye
and then what they're gonna do is help
me they could [ __ ] fondle my balls
make fun of me [ __ ] put their finger
in my nose
I don't give a [ __ ] just heal me but
it's a derma it's a German huh what if I
was a guy doctor and he flipped you over
and then boned you in the [ __ ] twenty
is it gonna heal me no no I mean like is
this is this you see like the specialist
the only specialist I could go to that's
gonna cure me and he's like I need to
bone in the aspirin he's gonna cure me I
don't give a [ __ ] you know I'm [ __ ] me
in the booty ho cuz I need to be cured
but all you have is the called terminal
illness yeah like this does like like
one out of [ __ ] like five people out
of the whole world I get this every year
you know and it's like not to know
that's it
actually no that jakey news article as
this doctor accepts unconventional
payments and he bangs you on the ass
there's like a jellyfish disease right
we're like I just [ __ ] turn into
jellyfish I can't move no more and then
the magic doctor comes and he's like Joe
you got [ __ ] do it do it I don't give
a [ __ ] I need to stay alive I don't know
that every day I don't want Brown
digging my bubble the difference with
your son he doesn't have a guy eat his
button no my buddy buddy I'm down with
the [ __ ] foot size dick like a
bedpost I don't give a [ __ ] wake me up I
need to stay alive but in your scenarios
the doctors letting you know who's about
to do that so you know what you're
getting yourself into what if you wake
up with a sore booty am i a lot of it
did I get cured I'll be so happy so you
do what your but you guys are so [ __ ]
you're looking at the glass half empty
okay I'm looking at it looking at its
butt half empty and he's looking at it
completely formed yeah yeah I'm looking
at the booty filled but my heart is
filled too cuz I'm alive but he's taking
advantage of you think about gorgeous
poor poor jazz having to go on without
Joe yeah instead she knows he got banged
hard in the ass and he's still alive and
this is for me I'm not saying this
should be right for the rest of the
world cuz people don't like how this
feels
but for me I'm like all right in order
to stay alive I had a [ __ ] suck 50
dicks but I'm alive [ __ ]
doctors okay I've just paid the man if
there if this is this was a for my
payment and it has to happen I will go
through this we know we know we aliens
we know you'll take dicks for a couple
pimples Alyssa he's like if it clears my
face up I'll let you the follow
I'll get game [ __ ] by a group of men
okay three [ __ ] bimbo yeah if you
clear there's one pimple on my nose you
could come on it front like you yeah
yeah there you go
okay thanks bud all right so this
Atlanta area dermatologist she has been
posting photos of herself while in
surgery making these music videos yeah
so what is unprofessional ass [ __ ] are
they good though the music video is good
is it musically shed Lee so musically no
hey man she's following her dreams
alright she's changing the lyrics to be
about what the procedure is
she's a parody person she actually you
tuber sounds like yeah she did upload on
youtube she went on CNN and tried to or
h ln which is a CNN sister network she
went and she defended these video saying
like well you know this idea was brought
on to me by a patient who was so excited
to get the procedure done so apparently
she's doing through that she's not even
qualified for it she's doing but lives
and breast implants she's a
dermatologist what anyways she was
saying that this is an idea of like a
patient's idea this is all kinds of
[ __ ] up oh like all kinds of [ __ ] up
so this patient was like yeah you know
what if you do like a video while I'm
under and you know you can use this as
an educational way to because you can
teach your shake my booty for a tort
video this a latin country no this is
Atlanta alright so I'm gonna show you
guys a video please she's dancing with
the scars she knows how to dance though
the position who shot these
controversial videos in the operating
room is now speaking out no patience to
make the videos educate the public about
cosmetic surgery in an entertaining way
there's not only education inspiration
there's celebration the cardiac arrest
during a tummy tuck
she is now an invalid looked after by
her son Oh dr. bootay who is a derma to
fight cosmetic surgeon says the adverse
outcomes were out of her control
oh I like all made up I have done
interview two because she's like talking
about herself like as if the patients
are talking about her like you're my
Savior you're such a great doctor you
she's a narcissist super nurses it's so
funny because she's talking to them as
if she's a pastor even animate she goes
it's uplifting it brings their spirit up
and had done nothing wrong
first of all she is but she [ __ ] up on
a tummy tuck and now that person's all
[ __ ] up right she actually has nine
lawsuits against her oh that's a lot and
then one of them yeah she left people on
the bond the diff like on the understand
it's like we want the victim to testify
and it's like I was unconscious she was
dancing around me singing apple bottom
jeans
this is like an onion article or like
some fake SNL skit for some reason I
thought she was gonna be Middle Eastern
or something I don't know I just doesn't
be Middle Eastern lady oh you're hoping
to see some Bollywood stuff yeah a
little bit yeah
it's so [ __ ] crazy she thinks she's
like a super inspiration and like we're
doing this for educational somebody sent
me a message hold on excuse me they told
me that my video of me dancing over an
unconscious person with the scalpel give
them the tissues it's not the actually
here youtubers say yeah my favorite part
was literally her with the scalpel
[ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] sharp dude or just like
[ __ ] an open wound everyone has a
mouth mask on she's spitting all over
the [ __ ] I know yeah exactly that's
another point that they brought up like
she's not even wearing her mask you know
opera they have to see her face kiss
come on house you can famous you
nobody'll know who you are when you're
walking around so she's claiming that
these patients did give her their
consent to do this either after the
procedure was done and but they were
still under or during the packaging
during the procedure while they were
under yeah I mean why didn't she just
hire actors or do this like separately
than the actual operation but she was
trying to like up her Instagram
followers she's trying to get real so
she's a [ __ ] 13 year old like what
tough luck so one of the patients that
did not give her consent to do this they
she had a phone call with her and then
she ends up so then that the media they
got a recording of that phone
conversation between them and she says
this quote they call me the dancing
doctor now you know Millie Millennials
love that so my social media followers
followers have grown exponentially since
the story broke because everybody loves
a dancing doctor right people come to me
from everywhere because they know the
results in your video I wanted you to
say something like hey
the curled the video the cutted video
for the dancing doctor in dr. boot a
boot a like a fancy way to say booty
yeah she got a big booty just patience
like I didn't even consent to this like
I feel humiliated this is not right but
all of her lawsuits they're all for
malpractice not necessarily because of
these videos but because of the result
like after elation mommy because she's
so busy dancing she's like ah [ __ ] my
lives aren't cut straight yeah focus on
the operation lady what the [ __ ] she's
like get my good slide so her license
has been suspended because yeah there's
the board was ailing she's a risk to
public safety [ __ ] oh [ __ ] but she's one
of those people were her intention was
so good and so positive that everything
else be damned because my intention was
so good I love it I love that she's so
festive that even though she has the
shower cap on she has to let that
Christmas hat come out a little bit
she's not even qualified for these
procedures I'm a punk surest but I do
brain search
yeah for sure
[Music]